ja ich fange man habe mit der frau und
quote im fußball und das gilt für mich
grundsätzlich aber im fußball noch mal
besonders mann soll frauen nicht nach
den quoten einsetzen sondern ganz klar
nach ihren qualitäten ich bin der
meinung dass man nur noch durchaus die
eine oder andere frau noch dazu gewinnen
kann und da gibt es bei uns schon ganz
gute beispiel erstens jetzt hier aus
diesem aus donata hopfen hat keiner mit
gerechnet ich glaube sie hat auch ein
bisschen glück am anfang hab weil
carsten schmidt der große chef von sky
nach hiernach hertha marschiert es sonst
wär würd ich war verrückt aber donata
hopfen ist eine absolute top lösung weil
sie ja
unternehmensstrategie beherrscht sie hat
schon früher hier für euch um die rechte
gekämpft mit seife weiß dass die haare
auf der zähne hat dass sie nicht so nett
aus
digitalisierung vermarktung sponsoring
da kommen 80 90 prozent der einnahmen
her nicht von den zuschauer fußball
zuschauer tickets um die zehn prozent
das muss man wissen was das für markus
und hier geht es nicht da drei ältere
herren sitzen das taten die besten
erfahrensten manager von bayern münchen
wo du hingehst mit einem menschen dort
haben die entschieden hat also diese
entscheidung basiert und ganz ganz
wichtig wenn du weiter guckt ob du jetzt
aus martina voss-tecklenburg
nationaltrainerin hat 125 länderspiele
alle bitten weltmeister europameister
nationaltrainern ist im aufsichtsrat von
fortuna düsseldorf oder ich komme daher
noch zu den schweizerinnen ich würde
jetzt nicht alle aufrufen oder bei
bayern münchen oder besten und jetzt ein
kind krieg hat da kathrin krüger fängt
dann wird er an dann kannst du auch
wieder sagen hier nehme ich mal jetzt
ein modell erfolg muss zwei schweizer
san standen dagegen da muss man sagen
frühere innen kennt sie ja gieseler die
genannt die kam dann natürlich mit der
kohle von
hoffmann la roche und hat man damals den
verein übernommen wurde präsidenten in
den sechs sieben jahre mit mama ist der
45 mal international gespielt hat auch
danach ganz wichtigen zentrum aufgebaut
und das muss man einfach sehen einfach
toll oder liebherr einig der letztlichen
der letzte liebherr familie liebt kennst
du katharina der vater hat nämlich
vorher mal so saß hinten übernommen
gekauft und an katharina hat den gehabt
er ist verstorben wir hatten für 20
millionen verkauft katharina für 220
millionen pfund verkauft und nur 80
liebe freude jetzt zu sehr schwer ist ja
ich höre ich finde es gibt banken erst
dann kommt die erste trainerin in der
bundesliga würde ich sagen im moment
noch nicht so weit um weil diese
schlechten oder gar nicht es gibt doch
trainerin ich habe gerade sein martina
voss jährigen bruder warum das geld ich
habe die erste trainerin aber auch eine
gute tragen kommt es dann nicht die
farbe inka grings einer der besten
nationale wanderinnen die wahlen der
vierten liga nord ist dann schwer dass
die frauen im fußball besondere spruch
da wirst du nicht im büro da gibt es um
andere dinge 100 ist und ich würde mir
wünschen und während der frau wird ist
noch nicht so weit aber schon gerne
keine die es jetzt selbst martina voss
matt hall of fame und 125 länderspiele
hat von nationaltrainerin die könnte das
fachlich vom wissen her machen aber so
von der ganzen potter vor den jungs
stehen und ihr insgesamt noch nicht das
konnte ich hoffe ja dass nicht mehr wird
essen und sogar also ist sie erst einmal
reiner calmund möchte ich am liebsten
umarmen weil ich mich sagen dass es
nicht um die quote geht sondern darum
wie tüchtig jemand ist frau oder mann
und die tüchtigste person soll an die
spitze jedes unternehmens kommen ich
werde ich mache mich wahnsinnig
unbeliebt bei den meisten frauen denn
ich bin gegen die quote ich möchte nicht
wie ein kaninchen sohn noch so irgendwo
gestreichelt werden und in extra
zugesetzt werden das möchte ich nicht
möchte wegen meiner leistung anerkannt
werden und befördert werden und die
meisten frauen die ich kenne die oben
sind haben das auch nicht durch die
quote geschafft sondern weil sie sich
durchgesetzt haben das ist das ist
wahnsinnig schwierig und ich weiß das
ist vielleicht vielleicht gibt es einige
bereiche wo man männer zwingen muss
frauen auch durch zu lassen aber das
setzt sich sowieso durch und in wahrheit
ist es nämlich so da wo ein unternehmen
in schwierigkeiten hat und sozusagen
droht abzusenken da holt man ganz gerne
frauen und sagt und sollen die das mal
probieren und auf diese weise setzen
sich frauen im übrigen auch durch
ich sagte hat ein insgesamt in der
gesamtabrechnung einen erstklassigen job
im alter können sich viele männer eine
ganz dicke scheibe von hat wir
diskutieren ja wir diskutieren jetzt
sozusagen nicht die frauenquote an sich
sondern wir sagen frauenquote und
fußball und ja ich euch so zuhört wenn
ich euch so zuhört denke ich ja ja eine
frauenquote brauchen wir nicht aber im
fußball wenn ich dich ganz richtig
verstanden habe dauert noch ein bisschen
das sagen leute wie du immer wenn sie
meinen die haben da nichts zu suchen
haben doch jetzt klar gesagt wie viel
sind aber das alleine bundesliga-trainer
machen jetzt das ist ein euro job und
man traut es den frauen eben noch nicht
zu das sind erfahren aber ich habe noch
hundertfach ich hab mich warum gerade
weil es ja nicht so jetzt warum du wirst
doch lange dabei wird du fragst mich
gesetzt wenn blut wird aber ich weiß
nicht mal 1000 aber es wird aber keine
erstliga verein auch im frühling ist du
hättest das machen können also gehört
ist eine frau zu trennen
ich spiele aber es passiere natürlich
andere ja da und warten bei der frauen
gute ja auch nicht entscheidend ist wir
haben der fußball in deutschland über
sieben millionen mitglieder über
150.000 mannschaften wir haben 25.000
vereine ungefähren wir sind froh dass
mit zwei millionen ehren haben will ich
haben wir sind froh dass ist dabei vier
oder fünf auch die das eine
staatspolitische aufgabe
wir machen jugendleiter schärferen
waschen die trikots garagen immer dabei
also bin ich aber trikots waschen gehen
da haben wir auch schwierigkeiten wolle
sie gar nicht immer wenn du in seinem
jugendbereich um sie ist diese 400 500
1000 freunde gibt es ein paar nette gute
trainerinnen aber in foren sind die
geschäftsführerin jugendleiterin kneipe
und kuchen backen oktoberfest
turnierschluss auto kassierst du kannst
du nicht verändern ein part war ich
lesen oder blauen karte heute möchte ich
einmal die frauen karte ziehen um dran
zu kommen ich hab nämlich eine frage
würden die spieler eine frau als
trainerin akzeptieren also wenn ich mir
jetzt überlegen die mannschaft nur
männer würden die
eine absolut gute berechtigte frage ich
glaube ich will was mich überrascht hat
damals hier die jetzt ein baby urlaub
ist also die karten oder kathrin mit
kathrin muss man sagen wie die jetzt ich
war einmal in los angeles da haben den
freundschaftsspielen macht habt mir
angeguckt wie die da in 34 so ein verein
wie bayern münchen durch das gesehen
habe sagt sagt sagt also noch alle
männer maschine und die wurde dann als
spiel als managerin als teammanager oder
wird das ist ja jetzt noch ein baby
pause
hundertprozentig akzeptiert das hätten
wir uns vor fünf oder sechs jahren nicht
vorstellen können es gibt jetzt mehrere
davon aber ein großes beispiel es dann
hier kathrin kröger das muss ich sagen
mit bayern münchen hat mit d'italia ist
voll habe sie akzeptiert aber der
nächste schritt
ein kleiner werden noch ein habe ich
noch ich habe verstanden es ist noch
nicht so weit also es kommt aber es ist
noch nicht so weit man jahreszahl keine
stunde 25 jahre zehn jahre hunderte
seiner trainerin der große zampano platz
ist werde ich im profifußball vermutlich
nicht mehr leben wenn ihre liebe
klassische keiner kann ich noch ein paar
jährchen länger leben wahrscheinlich mit
rechner und ich für mich als gesund und
ich fand diese frage von ihnen die fand
ich jetzt geradezu männerfeindlich also
würden die spieler eine frau als
trainerin akzeptieren was ist es da
wieder für eine unterstellung drin als
wütend wir männer in unserer reichen
schauspielerin eine frau kommt und
trauern wir hier nicht ist ja nur eine
frau im fußball sind wir männer unter
uns ich muss einfach folgendes sagen was
patricia riekel gesagt dass er absolut
entscheidende punkt das wichtigste was
wir haben bei uns im westen deutschland
schweiz überall ist das leistungsprinzip
das heißt jeder mensch wird aufgrund
seiner leistung beurteilt und im sport
gilt die leistung ganz besonders in der
politik etwas weniger darum kommt man
dort mit und weiter aber im sport muss
du leisten da ist die wahrheit auf dem
platz und wenn eine frau kommt die weiß
wie man eine american football
mannschaft trainiert zum beispiel wo
also der testosteron gehalt vermutlich
über der erlaubten
grenzwerten liegt der gesammelte der
ganzen mannschaft dann werden doch die
spieler das akzeptieren die leistung
zählt und das problem mit dieser ganzen
quotendiskussion ist darum ist das eine
gefährliche diskussion das ist in
deutschland auf dem vormarsch ist bei
uns auf dem vormarsch quoten setzen das
leistungsprinzip außer kraft sie tun den
frauen keinen gefallen das ist das
gegenteil unsere freiheitliche
gesellschaft denn die freie das besieger
uns wichtig freiheit und leistung gehirn
zusammen das leistungsprinzip ist das
ein größte freiheit ermöglicht man sie
haben sich durch reisen in die sendung
gebracht die ich auch noch eine quote
ich bin als quoten schweiz nicht hinein
geworden sie haben sich durch reisen
sie ganz genau dass du ein da gibt es
ein gehabt wenn es nur um das
leistungsprinzip besser verstanden wir
haben immer mehr leistungen geredet wir
haben sich frauen geredet
[Musik]